[Musique]
bonjour à tous curieuses et curieux ça
vous dirait un petit voyage en egypte en
mode exploration de cimetières d'oiseaux
momifié le long du nil c'est absolument
dingue des millions de mots midi bis et
d'oiseaux de proie ont été retrouvés
dans des dizaines de temples
attendait des millions mais pourquoi
autant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour décrypter ce mystère pas besoin de
faire appel à indiana jones direction le
musée des confluences de lyon un écrin
rempli de momies animal 2500 pièces au
total ceux qui ont fait la plus grande
collection du monde hors territoire
égyptien vraiment harrison ford peut
aller se rhabiller une équipe de
chercheurs lyonnais en géochimie ya mené
enquête sur 20 momies d'oiseaux 11 momie
10 bis a créé neuf rapaces et oui
l'egypte ancienne ses pyramides ces
temples ses pharaons et ses momies
d'animaux les égyptiens placé l'animal
au centre de leur vie d'ailleurs il n'ya
qu'à voir leur dieu presque tous
représenté sous les traits d'animaux
plutôt cool comme le faucon le crocodile
ou la punaise d'eau au fil des années
des millions de mots me d'animaux ont
été retrouvés dans des temples chat
serpent lionceaux gazelles mais surtout
une quantité incroyable d'oiseaux
momifié entre -700 et 300 après jésus
christ si les momies nous font rêver à
l'époque cela représentait plutôt un
énorme business on sait que certains
animaux comme les chats étaient élevés
pour être sacrifié momifiée et vendu au
peuple mais revenons à nos momie
d'oiseaux leur présence sur les sites
archéologiques est absolument écrasante
on y trouve principalement des ibis et
des rapaces sacrifier pour honorer
plusieurs divinités à tête de piaf on
sait qu'à l'époque de grande chasse aux
oiseaux étaient organisées dans la
nature pour les capturer mais quelques
mystère planait encore sur leur origine
comment savoir si ces millions de momies
était le fruit d'un business de
volatiles élevé pour être au momifié ou
s'ils étaient majoritairement issus
d'une chasse à l'état naturel ce qui
aurait pu avoir un impact sur leurs
populations sauvages et c'est là
qu'interviennent nausée faire en
géochimie géochimie et pour cette étude
les scientifiques se sont penchés sur la
signature de ces oiseaux mais non pas
celle au stylo mais bien leur signature
isotopique c'est à dire en gros les
variations de divers éléments chimiques
qui peuvent renseigner sur leur
provenance notamment il est donc
possible en explorant cette signature
d'obtenir des informations sur
l'alimentation et l'environnement des
oiseaux on peut y retrouver des traces
de sédiments par exemple ou fouiller
dans les proportions d'isotopes
d'éléments chimiques comme l'oxygène
l'azoté le soufre ou le carbone et tout
ça va nous donner de sacrés indices pour
élucider notre mystère c'est un peu la
carte d'identité de leur régime
alimentaire grâce aux isotopes stables
de l'oxygène il est possible de
déterminer l'origine de l'eau que les
oiseaux buvait à l'époque et dont les
signatures sont préservés dans leurs
hôtes des milliers d'années plus tard et
forcément les animaux sauvages n'ont pas
du tout le même régime qu'en captivité
si on faisait la même chose avec nos
volailles élevées en batterie et des
volailles sauvage la différence de diète
serez flagrante pour cette étude il
était important d'avoir un point de
départ et de comparaison afin de croiser
les résultats et pour ça les
scientifiques sont allés chercher cette
fois ci la signature isotopique de
momies du peuple de l'époque car la
momification n'était pas un processus
exclusivement réservé aux pharaons
franchement depuis que les prix de la
momification ont flambé c'est décidé je
m'auto momies qui voit là les profils
isotopique de ces momies humaines ont
révélé une diète homogène et locales
avec une consommation d'eau et de
nourriture produite le long de la vallée
du nil et finalement peu diversifiée
pour commencer les chercheurs ont
utilisé un protocole chimiques
permettant d'isoler les molécules
présentes dans les fragments d'os et de
plumes un processus délicat et à
l'échelle microscopique
mais rassurez-vous aucune momie n'a été
maltraité pendant la manipulation une
fois les signatures isotopiques obtenus
sur nos 20 momies les chercheurs ont
constaté que les oiseaux de proie avait
une diète bien plus diverses que celles
des humains ils ne passaient donc pas
l'essentiel de leur temps dans la vallée
du nil émigraient ponctuellement dans
d'autres régions le verdict tombe alors
ces oiseaux de proie été chassé à l'état
sauvage pour être ensuite momifiée et
offerts aux dieux concernant les ibis
les résultats sont un peu différents
leur régime est plus varié que celui des
humains mais les signatures sont
typiques des environnements du nil pas
d'élevage donc les populations de ces
oiseaux devait rester le long du cours
du nil émigrés peut-être saisonnièrement
plus en amont mais difficile de savoir
s'il vivait en semi liberté ou à l'état
sauvage dans tous les cas il est
intéressant de comprendre si cette
industrie de la momification a eu un
impact sur ces populations d'oiseaux
surtout quand on sait qu'aujourd'hui on
ne trouve plus 10 bis dans la vallée du
nil j'espère que cet épisode vous a plu
et qu'il aura su faire ressortir votre
âme de géochimistes n'hésitez pas à nous
laisser un commentaire un pouce bleus et
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner
et à ton reviendras tu t'es même pas
abonnés